Out of all the words that I dislike, the one
that makes me the most uncomfortable is “love.”
Hello all you crevice dwellers, Julian here
for DNews.
Have you ever heard a word that gives you
the heebee jeebies?
Some word that you just can’t stand hearing
because you have a visceral reaction to it?
And I don’t mean because the word is overused
and abused, like literally or ironic, and
I don’t mean because it’s a swear or potty
talk.
I mean a mostly innocent word, that’s minding
it’s own business doing it’s wordy thing,
giving form to an idea, and you just hate
this thing.
A word like…
Moist
A study published in PLOS ONE in April suggested
that 10 to 20% of you just cringed or even
felt physically ill when i said…
moist.
This is what psychologists call word aversion,
the phenomenon when a word itself feels unpleasant
or disgusting.
The reason for why certain words elicit that
response is still not fully understood but
there are a lot of competing hypotheses.
One that was explored in the PLOS one study
was the idea that some words just have a bad
combination of sounds.
They just don’t sit right when we say or
hear them, or even think about them.
Indeed participants in the study who were
moist averse were more likely to say this
was why they didn’t like moist.
It was also speculated that the very face
shape necessary to make these sounds contributed
to how people felt about certain words.
They have an exceptional “mouth feel.”
But the results supported a different hypothesis.
Namely that people don’t like the word because
of its connotation with sex, genitalia, or
bodily functions.
Across five experiments the results showed
that despite the reasons people speculated
they didn’t like the word moist, usually
they disliked words with related connotations
like damp or wet, especially after being primed
to think about sex or bodily functions.
They were even more OK with moist itself when
first primed to think about cake.
Meanwhile words with similar sounds like hoist
and rejoiced were rated as much more innocuous.
Not all studies agree with these findings,
others have concluded that just the sounds
of certain words conjure up strange feelings.
Baylor College of Medicine neuroscientist
David Eagleman
conducted experiments using made up words
and found the sounds of some were rated as
more unpleasant by participants than others.
Dr. Eagleman suggests something akin to synesthesia
is at work, where senses blend together and
certain sounds cause a visual or emotional
reaction.
This would help explain why many words with
a naughty association like panties are almost
vomit inducing to some, while totally innocent
words like crevice, ointment, and fiduciary
are repellant to others.
But the science on word aversion is fairly
unexplored.
Most of the data gathered has been in the
form of simple surveys asking people to rank
or list their least favorite words, and if
you couldn’t tell, I was trying to jam in
as many of those words into this episode as
I could.
Moist sits atop the list though, dripping
down over the damp cornucopia of other repugnant
locutions below it.
And its popular unpopularity gives rise to
another possibility: maybe all the moist hate
is just a fad.
Maybe so many people dislike moist because
so many people dislike moist.
It’s become a cultural phenomenon at this
point, having appeared as a plot point in
a couple TV shows like How I Met Your Mother
and Dead Like Me.
In a few years or decades maybe we’ll all
move on and irrationally hate some other poor
word that was just doing it’s job.
My vote is for “gorgeous.”
If you don’t like the word moist because
of its relationship with sex and sexuality,
Laci Green made many a great video for DNews
back in the day that may help you come to
terms with it.
Like this one wherein she talks about literal
boners!
Are there any
weird words you can’t stand hearing?